non mais je vous parlais bien un stand
du ku klux klan et si vous avez une
revendication importante à formuler pour
vous même ou pour une cause bref si vous
voulez vous montrer un seul endroit à
partir d'aujourd'hui atlanta en géorgie
un état du sud des états unis où s'ouvre
donc la convention démocrate qui
désignera son candidat à la maison
blanche de nombreuses associations ont
bien compris cela hier à atlanta fais
mais je voulais site
les erythréens hostiles au gouvernement
éthiopien les sans-logis les militants
homosexuels et partisans des droits des
animaux ont manifesté mais aussi des
amis du ku klux klan sellem organisation
raciste
cette manifestation avait été interdite
mais malgré cela plusieurs dizaines de
partisans de ce mouvement qui s'intitule
nationalistes sont descendus dans la rue
ils ont été aussitôt isolés par la
police sous l'oeil des
contre-manifestants reportage paul nahon
et francis friedland nous sommes atlanta
à quelques centaines de mètres à peine
de la convention démocrate
ici ces manifestants protestent contre
un défilé que veut organiser le cul cul
ce clan dans une autre partie de la
ville
le cul cul ce clan est une organisation
encore très puissants dans le sud des
états unis
le racisme est le fondement de son
idéologie
je vais ça représente une organisation
chrétienne qui est contre ce qui n'est
pas chrétien à l'autre bout de la ville
les troupes du ku klux klan qui à la
dernière minute ont été empêchées de
défiler
la police craignait en effet des heurts
violents à quelques heures de
l'ouverture de la convention
voici quelques morceaux choisis de leur
idéologie
nous sommes une race supérieure les
noirs avec les noirs ici on travaille
très dur et qu'est ce qu'on voit tous
ces sales [ __ ] qui nous piquent notre
fric pour acheter des voitures ils ne
foutent rien j'en ai ras-le-bol nous on
veut l'argent car on travaille plus
question de leur fils et un rond
c'étaient les esclaves ils sont libres
qu'on les renvoie maintenant chez eux je
ramenais contre jackson et doukha qui
tousse et communistes et cpd qui sont en
ville j'espère qu'ils vont tous attrapé
le sida puis zone noire s'est approché
d'eux les noirs représentent 60% de la
population atlanta et dans le sud du
pays la police est arrivée très vite car
plusieurs fois déjà le plus que ce clan
en à lyncher en géorgie et en alabama le
en taule pas de pitié ont crié les
membres du clan le clan est encore une
terrible réalité aux états unis
[Applaudissements]